чому вона так ще команда називається
курити це називається видавалася слова
велику компанію на священика та тайці
торгівлі на калібр їх ики там торгуються
російської федерації зараз cool ice
2014 Україна
адже область занапастимо російського розуму за
сьогодні
аолен заява чого помотає мій стій на
купив просив когось українська
економіка має і мало економіка
своєму вашому буде власного те й
фінансово тієї росії вони на queen стіл і
Цього року три новини просто українці
він і будете ти на зміну нам швидко
українці думка морильйону
папір не часто закритий за коментарі
страйк на папір треба плутати
нашим казани магазин як вибирати ми
сьогодні бачуна заходьте на густоту
чому ж правильно фарбуватись новинок ніж
на 100 рік для України вже здають на
ризиково залишити економічно ще нашу
лектор знак готелю і називається лаяти
тата реєстрі гасла і робот ставку не на
роздратування і у нас на хвилину гонках
за
вона ж субсидій і посадку України на
злість на ринковому році
нас дуже люблять буває і в нас дали
штиль у комітеті там добре все
займаються чим закону ми боремося звуть
на позицію в порядку справі він зламаний і
мати промовляли точніше там слова на
а формату там слова не пішов і
травня у нас буде змі до голови комітету ми
душі дуже кроків акули mango камери
знає і вам поміняв і пошила та ми теж
стріляючий грудях
такого я лігво залі позиції пам'ятаєш не
болить у ці дні верховній раді
їм із завгодно це порожній